>>> UKRAINE IS NOW CALLING
RUSSIA'S AIR STRIKES, AND I'M
QUOTING NOW, AIR GENOCIDE, AND
THE COUNTRY IS WORKING TO
RESTORE POWER OUTAGES AFTER
MOSCOW'S LATEST MASSIVE ASSAULT.
CNN'S SENIOR INTERNATIONAL
CORRESPONDENT BEN WEDEMAN IS IN
KYIV FOR US TONIGHT.
>> Reporter: THE KREMLIN
LAUNCHED A FRESH ROUND OF DRONE
ATTACKS FRIDAY.
UKRAINE SAID IT KNOCKED OUT 16
OF THE IRANIAN MADE KAMIKAZE
DRONES INTENDED FOR
INFRASTRUCTURE TARGETS.
SEVEN FELL IN THE CAPITAL, KYIV,
WHERE AIR RAID SIRENS RANG OUT
SHORTLY AFTER 2:00 A.M.
CHILD'S CORNER, OUR CHILD USED
TO READ HERE.
HE AND HIS PARTNER CARRIED THEIR
DAUGHTER TO SAFETY SHORTLY
BEFORE A DRONE WAS SHOT DOWN
NEARBY, HURLING DEBRIS INTO
THEIR HOME.
WE'RE LUCKY OUR CHILD WASN'T
HERE, HE SAYS.
WINDOWS WERE BLOWN OUT.
HERE YOU CAN SEE A PENETRATING
HOLE, SHRAPNEL HOLES ALL OVER.
EVERYTHING IS DAMAGED AND A
CHILD WOULD HAVE BEEN SLEEPING
HERE.
MEANWHILE, FIGHTING IN THE EAST
GRINDS ON.
OVERNIGHT RUSSIAN FORCES SHELLED
ALONG THE DONETSK FRONT LINE.
FIELD DOCTORS SEE THE
DEVELOPMENTS FIRSTHAND.
SIGNIFICANTLY LESS ARTILLERY
DAMAGE THAN WE WERE USED TO SAYS
THIS DOCTOR.
THE FIGHTING DISTANCE GOES FROM
15 METERS TO 1 KILOMETER.
THE DISTANCE BETWEEN ARMIES IS
VERY SMALL.
ON FRIDAY, PRESIDENT PUTIN HELD
A VIRTUAL MEETING WITH CHINESE
PRESIDENT XI JINPING, INVITING
HIM FOR A STATE VISIT IN THE
SPRING.
XI ACCEPTED THE INVITATION.
PUTIN CLAIMED RELATIONS BETWEEN
RUSSIA AND CHINA WERE THE BEST
IN HISTORY, DESPITE WHAT HE
CALLED UNPRECEDENTED PRESSURE
AND PROVOCATION FROM THE WEST.
THE PROPAGANDA WAR JUST AS
IMPORTANT AS THE WAR RAGING ON A
GRIDLOCKED BATTLEFIELD.
AND PRESIDENT PUTIN SAID HE
WANTS TO INTENSIFY
MILITARY-TO-MILITARY COOPERATION
WITH THE CHINESE, THIS AFTER HIS
INVASION OF UKRAINE HAS CAREENED
FROM ONE SETBACK TO ANOTHER.
NOW, THE CHINESE HAVE
RHETORICALLY BACKED MOSCOW IN
THIS CONFLICT, BUT HAVE YET TO
PROVIDE IT WITH ANY MILITARY
HARDWARE, WARY OF WESTERN
SANCTIONS.
>> GOOD POINT.
BEN WEDEMAN, STAY SAFE OVER
THERE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
>>> LET'S DIG DEEPER.
JOINING US, CNN MILITARY
ANALYST, RETIRED U.S. ARMY
GENERAL, WESLEY CLARK, THE
FORMER NATO SUPREME ALLY.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THIS ATTEMPT
BY VLADIMIR PUTIN AND XI JINPING
TO ACTUALLY TRY TO PROJECT
STRENGTH?
>> THAT'S WHAT THEY'VE BEEN
WANTING TO DO ALL ALONG.
THEY SIGNED A STRATEGIC ALLIANCE
BEFORE THE WAR BEGAN IN 2022,
BUT CHINA HASN'T BEEN VERY
FORTHCOMING.
THEY UNDERSTAND THE POWER OF THE
SANCTIONS.
THEY ALSO LOOK AT RUSSIA AS A
LOSING ALLY AND THEY'RE NOT SO
ANXIOUS TO GET INTO THAT.
AND FINALLY, WOLF, THINK OF IT
FROM CHINA'S PERSPECTIVE.
THEY LIKE RUSSIAN TECHNOLOGY,
THEY CERTAINLY WANT
HYDROCARBONS, BUT THE LAST THING
XI JINPING REALLY WANTS IS A
SUPER EMPOWERED REBUILT SOVIET
UNION ON CHINA'S BORDER.
SO A WEAK RUSSIA THAT IS COMING
TO HIM FOR HELP, THAT'S PRETTY
SATISFYING FOR PRESIDENT XI.
>> GOOD POINT.
WALK US THROUGH WHAT'S HAPPENING
RIGHT NOW ON THE BATTLEFIELD,
GENERAL, WITH THIS BRUTAL TRENCH
WARFARE IN THE EAST, FOR
EXAMPLE.
>> YEAH, WE'RE IN A STRATEGIC
STALEMATE, AND THE REASON IS
RUSSIA'S LOST ITS OFFENSIVE
CAPACITY, BUT THE UKRAINIANS
HAVE NOT BEEN -- THEY DON'T HAVE
ENOUGH ARTILLERY, THEY DON'T
HAVE ENOUGH AMMUNITION, THEY
DON'T HAVE THE DRONES, THE
FIGHTER AIRCRAFT, THEY DON'T
HAVE NEW TANKS.
SO THEY REALLY DON'T HAVE THE
OFFENSIVE FIRE POWER TO FINISH
THIS THING OFF.
AND IN MY VIEW, THE RIGHT WAY TO
DO IT IS TO GIVE THEM THAT
CAPABILITY, GET RUSSIA OUT OF
UKRAINE AND THEN THERE'S A
REASONABLE POSSIBILITY THAT WE
COULD HAVE PEACE TALKS.
BUT, INSTEAD, IT'S A GRINDING
STALEMATE WAITING, I GUESS, FOR
RUSSIA TO EITHER BLEED UKRAINE
OUT OR FOR THE WEST TO FINALLY
PUT EFFECTIVE WAR CRIMES ACTIONS
AGAINST PRESIDENT PUTIN THAT
WOULD BRING HIM TO HEEL AND CUT
OFF ANY INTERNATIONAL SUPPORT.
>> WE'LL SEE IF THAT HAPPENS.
UKRAINE NOW SAYS THAT SINCE
PUTIN INVADED UKRAINE LAST
FEBRUARY, GENERAL, UKRAINE HAS
LIBERATED ABOUT 1,800 UKRAINIAN
SETTLEMENTS FROM RUSSIAN
OCCUPATION.
DOES THAT BOLSTER THE UKRAINIANS
AS THIS AWFUL WAR DRAGS ON?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
THE FACT THAT UKRAINE COULD
FIGHT BACK, HOLD ITS OWN AND
THEN RECAPTURE TERRITORY, IT
SAYS TO THE WORLD THAT RUSSIA IS
CAPABLE OF BEING DEFEATED,
RUSSIA IS CAPABLE OF BEING
PUSHED COMPLETELY OUT OF
UKRAINE.
BUT, WOLF, THE BATTLEFIELD IS
CHANGING, BECAUSE WHAT THE
RUSSIANS HAVE DONE IS REALLY
ENTRENCH THEMSELVES IN DONBAS.
AND SO IT'S NOT GOING TO BE LIKE
THE EASY TAKEOVER OF THE KHARKIV
AND NORTHEAST THAT OCCURRED IN
SEPTEMBER.
THE FIGHTING THAT UKRAINE IS
GOING TO HAVE TO GO THROUGH IS
THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE TO HAVE
MASS ARTILLERY, THEY'RE GOING TO
HAVE TO HAVE OVERWHELMING COMBAT
POWER AND DO A BREAKTHROUGH OF
THE RUSSIAN LINES.
THEY'RE NOT EQUIPPED TO DO THAT
YET.
THEY'RE ASKING THE UNITED STATES
FOR THAT KIND OF SUPPORT.
REALLY, ONLY THE UNITED STATES